let's see the kangaroo video all right
so this guy he's in Australia obviously
and they're hunting and he's got a dog
you know a retriever of some sort and
the dog ends up getting attacked by a
kangaroo oh the dog bites it [ __ ]
giant crow has it in the headlock yeah
kangaroo you [ __ ] with a kangaroo bro
the man has to come and help his dog
with his bare hands
to save it from this kangaroo check this
out running you guys literally running
and the kangaroo is not running away
because he had the kangaroo literally
the kangaroo is trying to choke the dog
to death and the guys gonna bomb the
kangaroo he's like what the [ __ ] is it
really stunned the kangaroo Wow he just
punched it in the kangaroo got pushed
punked out right in the [ __ ] jaw and
I'm glad he did there are some people
that think that the guy was out you know
he shouldn't have I'm glad he didn't
teach that kangaroo a lesson if you want
to choke a dog out you want to act like
a man well guess what
look at the seed that's how strong a
kangaroo is it can stand up on its tail
you see it kicking the dog in the
beginning of that it had the dog in a
headlock and then it balanced itself on
its tail so it could get its legs up and
kick it and he did the right thing by
punching because that kangaroo was
jumping and was probably setting up that
Kanger was probably setting up to kick
him or gut him look at his hands go up
in the air when no one's ever treated
that microphone like that they talked
into it oh they got me
that kangaroo was in shock like this
[ __ ] means business yeah yeah
but it also the kangaroo is ready you
can see the kangaroo is hopping getting
ready to could they jump up and they'll
kick you into his [ __ ] hind leg
balance on the tail yeah yeah and they
got the clothes right there the kangaroo
is kind of hopping it looks like he's
setting up - he's getting ready but look
at this guy's a guy from Gilmore Girls
it's the boyfriend from Gilmore Girls
the guys in position shot kangaroos
faces like the kangaroo he [ __ ] him up
if that kangaroo you can tell he's
balancing on his tail
if he didn't have his teo that kangaroo
would have been knocked the [ __ ] out on
the floor it would have been on the
[ __ ] ground if not for that big thick
tail it's so weird to see the kangaroo
not running away but actually standing
there to fight boom and then he got you
got a row I love that that's it that's
just that's just a reminder we are at
the top of the food chain okay that's
how I stand up for my wife
punching kangaroos you do that right if
that kangaroo had Bonnie in a chokehold
[ __ ] no I'd be calling the insurance
company can we operate can we hop it can
we up it hey by the way there were other
dogs and they didn't help but [ __ ]
[ __ ]
dogs are Stu well you see those you ever
see the [ __ ] nails on the kangaroo
there's one word it's one lookin in the
house in the window the can yo it's real
creepy the kangaroo is standing outside
this person shouts find that video it's
on out something and and staring in the
house and it's like a dead devil Adrien
looked at you like [ __ ] you know I guess
you're like find that video it's on
something he's like huh
I mean yeah it's tough Gerardus he found
that that's he's good look at look at
the nails oh my god he really looks like
Freddie all right way he's just showing
him he's got real thick sharp dinosaur
nails and he looks like he's Freddy
Krueger just across your face like that
it would rip your [ __ ] face off yeah
look at it look at his [ __ ] muscles
too yeah that is a strong ass kangaroo
he's got abs he's got the rift holy God
look at his biceps what's he doing this
kangaroo doesn't [ __ ] around they're not
so lovable after all I loved seeing him
get punched in the face though he
deserved to get punched in the face Adam
all right activists who are upset about
this some people were just people
watching it were like I didn't mean to
punch him oh really
they weren't upset about the dog being
[ __ ] choke down exactly well that's
just animals being animals well we're
animals we are the strongest animals and
we punch other animals in the [ __ ]
face yes because we can ball up our
fists except thumbs
we have thumbs and that we have tools
and that makes us better yes right and
we have interns and we have interns and
they can get a sandwiches if we want
them and if we need to see a video we
could just say find that video it's on a
thing
they don't find it it's their [ __ ]
fault for being idiots yeah right and
they can get fired they can get fired
not us though not me Tom I guess that's
true that's true
yeah he could you could get not asked
back